hi everyone welcome to this the 100th
episode of the into the impossible
podcast
i am your fearful host professor brian
keating
and today it is an exceptionally
important milestone
in addition to the 100th episode but it
is the first time that we are having on
a real live nobel prize winning
experimental astrophysicist
on this podcast and our guest today
barry barish is
fitting because he's been a mentor to me
and i try to act
as a mentor to my students and those
that i get the privilege of
interacting with both at ucsd and around
the world from the south pole
to south africa to south california
to all points and places in between and
i hope that you enjoy these
these uh very interesting interviews
that i get to do
with thought leaders and other people
around the world but this one is very
special barry
is an avuncular figure as a mentor and
as somebody who
really represents a role model to me and
to literally
millions of people around the world we
spoke today for a nice uh episode that's
slightly over an hour and it's just
chock full of nuggets of wisdom that
only barry can provide including what it
was like to
think about his career being over when
the super conducting super collider was
canceled in 1993
to the stunning turn of events that led
to his nobel prize
only because the superconducting super
collider was canceled
we get into that and other details such
as
what it's like to see albert einstein's
name
in a book that you get to sign and uh
finally one of the most interesting
tidbits of any of my guests
on this uh past 100 sent centenary
episode
of the into the impossible podcast barry
describes his battles
that wage even until this day with the
imposter syndrome
and i think it's uh quite uh startling
and amazing
and revealing and in its vulnerability
that even a nobel prize winner
can feel the imposter syndrome and be
afflicted with it more or less his whole
life
and i think that really serves the
purpose of what i'm trying to do in this
podcast which is to humanize
these uh maximum minds of our multiverse
of ideas
and these people that i get to have the
privilege to interview
really reveal themselves in a way which
i'm hoping is unique and i hope that you
too will enjoy it
and come along with me as we go further
and further into the impossible and the
survey
like alexander the great hopefully i
won't weep
for the lack of discovery of new
intellectual worlds to conquer
as as i try to recreate the
work of alexander the great maybe i'm
alexander the mediocre
but in any case i wish that you will
continue on this journey
please do subscribe i read every review
on itunes every
comment and critique helpful or not
on youtube i try to do that as well so i
i want to express my sincere gratitude
for all uh of your support the listening
audience
and the viewing audience you really make
this possible
and inspire me and i hope that these
guests inspire you
so please sit back and enjoy this
episode with the one and only
professor barry barish of caltech and
the university of california riverside
you'll find out why barry made the move
there in just a second
enjoy this episode
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]
i want to start with how you barry got
to be involved in ligo it all started in
1994
after the cancellation of the
superconducting super collider
you were involved with that very deeply
uh
officially officially but i i was
actually in
caltech where i go to where i my whole
career rather than getting a degree in
berkeley
degrees in berkeley i've been at caltech
and the one
one unique thing about caltech is it's
basically a zero growth
uh institution it's within
10 or 15 percent the same size as it was
when i came and i
lost all my hair in the meantime so uh
the the question has always been how you
stay at the forefront of science
without growth it's a it's a difficult
problem
caltech doesn't have a wonderful formula
for it but i think the
underneath uh scheme is the
no appointment
new appointment whether it's from a
retirement or
somebody just leaving is
belongs in any particular area or at any
particular individual so we always
uh basically it's a completely open
search
and which means that there's a lot of uh
discussion about what areas we might go
in or what individuals we might attract
and so forth
i i started on the caltech faculty the
same year as uh my colleague
kipthorn and so we've been good friends
since
the you know opening receptions and
stuff you go to when you
start on the faculty and uh i
was interested in
his work on gravitational waves which
was purely theoretical and general
relativity
uh from the early days
uh but then at some point uh
we talked about whether and when to try
to get
such a effort at caltech itself and
uh i was against it in the early days
because i didn't like the technique the
technique that was being pursued was
what are called resident bars and
it turns out there's long history in
that which i won't go into but that's
not the point the point is technically i
thought it was a bad idea
because if you have a big bar it's a
great big bar of aluminum
and that big bar gets excited by
basically a gravitational wave going
through it
changes its shape a little bit and if
your sensors are good enough you can
sense that change in shape but i think
any of us know if you walk up to a big
bar of metal and you bang it it rings at
some frequency
uh so that the bar has this feature that
it likes some particular
frequency and not other frequencies and
it's usually around a thousand hertz and
for a big bar of aluminum
and then the problem i always felt was
it's
why would gravitational waves pick to be
at a thousand hertz that you really
wanted to search broadband
and so i didn't like the technique even
though i followed it from the very early
days
and although it was pursued by a
scientist who was
very good technically and had good ideas
but was not a very good scientist so he
thought he discovered or maybe he wanted
to discover too much gravitational waves
so there was a there was a yeah yeah
there was assorted history but i
it didn't involve me i was in particle
physics so i was more
involved with kip and the fact that it
was the wrong technique when
when the alternate technique which we
used which is kind of behind me an
interferometer
emerged i liked it immediately because
of the fact that it's broadband uh
basically there's nothing that picks one
frequency over another except where
you're
able to uh uh work
uh technically and so in our case
uh we work on the earth's surface and on
the earth's surface the
uh evolution has been
pretty good at picking where you can
work and so our ears
we communicate with each other in what
we call the audio band where we can talk
to each other
and that's because the earth is much too
noisy if you go to lower frequencies
animals go a little bit lower but not
much uh the shake the earth just shakes
too much
and the highest frequencies you can't
sample very well so
kind of like music we go from 10 hertz
to 10 000
hertz and that's where you can work on
the earth's surface but the same
technique can be used elsewhere like in
space
and cover different frequencies so to me
it was really the right technique
if you could make it work well enough
and
there was some promising work done early
some by kip thor by uh ray wyatt's at
mit
but in particular in germany where they
had
had uh uh build a small test
interferometer
and so the question came up when we were
talking about making the early 1980s
making a new
experimental appointment in in our
department
i kind of teamed up with kip and some
others
to make that appointment be in
in uh an experimentalist
or maybe two in uh uh gravitational
waves
so it wasn't me doing it and from that
day on we first we attracted uh
ron dreever and then
um and we had a couple assistant
professors but they didn't get tenure
uh it's hard to get tenure when you
don't discover something and you're just
doing technical work uh and uh
that went on for you know kind of a
decade of uh
of r d where kyle tech was one of the
players
but it was done a lot of places in the
world
and at some point it became
competitive with the bars the bars kept
becoming better and better
because you could make them quieter by
cooling them
to low temperature and then they got
quieter
but they still only worked at this you
know one frequency
our small frequency band uh but so by
you know the late 1980s or early 1990s
it was
pretty clear to me that the future was
with
interferometers and that you could at
least from
the r d that had been done compete
technically of making it
as quiet and uh
so um i was part of
kind of caltech when you have something
that's pretty big and has a lot of
resources
we had an oversight group so i was on
the oversight group
of this but i was practicing particle
physicists during this whole
time and then
as you said i was working on the super
collider
i was co-leader of one of the two
experiments that was to be done there so
i should have been
discovering the higgs boson which was
our great goal
uh but we didn't get canceled but the
collider got cancelled
and neither my colleague bill willis
from columbia and i were the leaders of
it
uh decided to go on to cern where they
were doing the same thing
uh not the same thing exactly but i'm in
the same physics school
and um at that point uh it turned out
that uh
they wanted new leadership in light ago
at caltech and
and that's when i came in it wasn't an
approved experiment yet
i mean it had been on the verge but it
wasn't funded
how was it to leave the field that you
had you know grown up in maturity
as a as a scientist of age as an article
physicist
um was it scary to change oh
invigorating
i i why would it be scary i think
the only reason that things get scary is
if you're just so comfortable in what
you're doing which probably means
you're not pushing yourself or doing
anything very interesting so
i've always done different things i've
worked on designing accelerators i've
worked on
all kinds of accelerators i've worked
underground
on a very different kind of experiment
looking for magnetic monopoles
and then i worked on the supercollider
but not on the accelerator on
the experiment where the big challenge
was how you could
uh actually we thought that
and it ends up being true but not
because i had the great insight that the
most sensitive way you could look for
the higgs boson was to
look for the production of it to decay
into two photons
that's a very difficult challenge
because
photons convert to electrons if you go
through any material and you need
material to make detections
so yeah there's this battle of making a
good enough detector but
basically making it not have any any
material
or as little as possible but anyway
changing to gravitational waves first
uh theoretically uh general relativity
is
as uh you know kind of abstract as it
seems
uh is actually easier
than quantum field theory to understand
furniture for me
as an experimentalist i can at least
write down the equations of general
relativity and try to solve them
quantum field theory is abstract because
it has quantum mechanics buried into
field theory and it's very
very difficult so as an experimentalist
you like to understand as well as
possible and as deeply as possible
the science that you're doing changing
the gravitational waves didn't
put me into a worse problem there i mean
it's
difficult to understand einstein's
equations but
but i felt as comfortable or more
comfortable than
with a quantum field theory so
that part was okay technically i had
followed it quite closely for
a long time there was nothing about it
technically from my background
that scared me uh i i know
the challenges that we had but i didn't
think that i needed some
30 years in this field or something to
be able to attack those they're quite
different fundamentally they're
different in that
in particle physics we've
collided particles together for a long
long time on different kinds of
accelerators and there's all kinds of
things that happen
and you look for something that happens
on top of a lot of physics
so if you remember the discovery of the
higgs boson
it was a very tiny effect they usually
suppress the zero and they
show it a very tiny effect
on a background but the background is
very well
understood by a lot of physics that's
been measured
and so you can look to see a small
effect and see that it has
statistical significance over a physics
background
and that's comfortable in the sense that
you understand what's there other than
what you
detect but it's very limiting because
the signal the noise can never ever be
made any better than
what happens and that's the problem
they're dealing with now at cern
so they discovered the higgs boson but
pursuing
uh the higgs boson itself will take
another kind of
device in any real deep way
and in looking at what else is going on
they're limited by the fact that
maybe they're missing everything because
it's below
physics that drowns it out
gravitational waves is a different
problem we're not limited there is no
physics underneath
so we're completely limited by how well
we can see a signal over a technical
background
and certainly dealing with technical
things that limit you
is i can reduce them i can't reduce
physics and it's the reason
why we've done so much better than say
cern
after a big discovery so if you look at
since the higgs they're really
struggling to go past that
a lot of my colleagues work in that and
that's not because they're not smart
and they're not doing great uh technical
things
but it's because there's a fundamental
problem they're limited by the physics
in our case we're not we're limited by
how much the ground shakes and
how much rf pickup there is all kinds of
just technical problems
which we know how to make better we mean
we've done pretty well to get where we
are but we know how to make it better
and each time we make it better we uh
the signals stand out more and we see
more things so we've seen
a lot since uh the discovery which is
only
a few years ago we have a feature that
we're measuring in amplitude and not a
power
and so if we if we make it twice as good
we see twice as far out and that's eight
times as much of the
universe i want to make a controversial
claim that
from my vantage point i remember very
well jerry garalnick
my professors at brown in 1993 when the
superconducting super collateral was
cancelled
it was like a wake on the particle
physics floor at brown university where
i was a grad student
but i want to make the controversial
claim that perhaps it was good for you
because a
it freed you up to do ligo and b
maybe a lot could happen uh between say
the nobel prize that you received for
ligo
and then lowball prize that wasn't
received by those working on the
large hadron collider which ultimately
did detect the higgs
since the higgs the ssc was also
designed to detect the higgs
the europeans detected it instead of the
americans so maybe perhaps the americans
didn't get much of the glory but not
only experimentalists got any of the
share of the nobel prize
for the discovery of the so-called higgs
boson
unlike ligo where the experimentalists
with the exception of kipp did win
the leaders did win you and barry you
and
ray weiss win the nobel prize so looking
back serendipitously maybe it was one of
the best things that ever happened to
you
well i i think it what you uh yeah
that's those kind of game playing i
don't know
but i think what you say is true in the
sense that
i i at least i like to think that
we detected gravitational waves when we
did
that partially because of myself and
we that's measurably true because this
is uh in competition with the italian
french collaboration
and virgo who were approved in that
actually
a half a year before we were and we were
in a race to
detect gravitational waves that took
them three years longer
than us uh even though it took us a long
time
and uh uh they're still not getting
caught up and i think that's
uh a lot to do with the way we approach
the problem because
they're using interferometry as well but
and they had as much resources as we did
uh and they had some smart people but i
think we made some decisions that uh
that enabled us to do better
and uh they're not all due to me but i
think uh
some of them are due to me and some of
them are maybe due to the
atmosphere that enabled us to develop
that way that i was
at least partially responsible for
[Music]
when you look at the challenges of
running a big project like this like
ligo as you say
science is fairly this type of science
is really classical physics it's easy to
understand
and yet i wonder if you know at a
personal level if we get a little bit
less technical how did you feel on july
4th 2012
when this announcement was made that the
higgs was discovered by two teams at
cern knowing that you guys were years
away
you and ligo were years away and maybe
never would detect the signals that you
were seeking
did you ever feel at that particular
moment back in 2012 before the
nobel prize was awarded that maybe i
made a wrong decision
uh no i i
i don't maybe it's my personality i
don't really look back though
maybe at some level but i wasn't really
very evident i
i was really i was in melbourne in
australia at the time of the official
but i
but they had three sigma before that it
was built because they had to build up
this signal so
it wasn't as much of maybe a surprise
uh i was really happy for them it's a
lot of my closest colleagues and and
uh i i think
what i don't like and i know it's one of
the things that you're
uh that you criticize in your book and
so forth
i think the experimental feat was a big
one
and the credit uh completely went to a
theorist that did something 60 years ago
so i
i think that that i'm not just talking
about the nobel prize but that's an
example of it and i think that uh
it's hard to do because in this case
there
wasn't one individual that you could
pick out very well in
the way it's done but if uh
skipping the topic i know you love heart
hate or something
uh that if nobel prizes were given like
the beast prize that
certain or or the experiments would have
gotten a nobel prize
and uh in in a sense i i
even at that time in 2012 i felt that
that
many of my colleagues had gone there
they've done well i mean
young people got tenure and it is a big
thing and so forth
but
but it there it wasn't
there wasn't any magic in doing it it
was just
really hard uh it was the technical
development of silicon
using silicon detectors that enabled
them to get the resolution you needed
close to the vertex we may have had
trouble doing it earlier at the ssc
because
silicon was such a key in the final
detection if you actually look at it
technically
we use silicon too but silicon detectors
weren't developed as well
in the in the time when i was working on
it so we
it was new silicon detectors had been
used
to discover the top port and we grabbed
it for the ssc but
they were being developed by physicists
not by industry and what changed is
silicon became something developed
because of other uses for circuitry and
stuff by
industry and then it really changed in
being able to get
very low amount of material and very
good spatial resolution
that you needed on these detectors very
close to the vertex
what fascinates you the most about ligo
is it the gravitational wave
aspect of it is it the technical
challenge
is it the black holes themselves is the
neutron stars
all of which has been discovered really
directly for the first time
my attraction to the field uh
is that i think i always thought i mean
that a discovery is a big thing itself
but i always thought that
it represented uh a
new way of grant opening up a new way
that she could do
exploratory science uh basically a new
way to look at the sky
using gravity instead of using photons
and that
meant that we could look at the sky
in principle uh to uh
do a new kind of astronomy well i'm not
an astronomer so that's great but still
i can appreciate it uh i always thought
more
that closer to your field
then i still don't know how to do it but
it's the ultimate way to study the early
universe
the reason of course being that the
cosmic microwave background
is only good to look a few hundred
thousand years after the big bang
and if you want to look earlier you need
something that's not absorbed i have
been
interested in that from the fact that
earlier i worked with neutrinos
and i used to think that was the key but
the trouble is the
it's technically almost impossible i
think uh
and uh this although we don't know how
to do it
uh it's not gonna happen in the next few
years unless something's really
uh different than we expect uh we look
for it we look for signals from the
universe but we don't think we'll see
them uh because we work at stitch high
frequency
but i always thought that that was the
attract an attraction i also
thought there was another attraction
which again i can only speak about
romantically
like the early universe i can't tell you
we can do it but you said well how why
was i
attracted i think this is a general
approach that eventually may give us the
key to
actually because gravitational waves
aren't absorbed
if we can see them from the earth
directly from the early universe
we can see back to the first instance of
the air of the universe instead of a few
hundred thousand years after
and we also in another way
should be able to see something
equivalent to the cosmic microwave
background with neutrinos if you were
able to
do it so both ways that it is
is good i also as of as coming from
from quantum physics have always felt
that we should be terribly embarrassed
with physicists
that we think we understand physics but
we have two wonderful theories of
physics quantum
quantum physics basically or uh quantum
field theory that explains almost
anything that happens at cern
or when you collide particles together
and then we have another great theory
called general relativity
which is greater than relativistic
effects and
long distances so we have a great theory
at long distances and relative
relativistic effects we have a great
theory at short distances
and never the twain shall meet and and
somehow
theorists have been working on how to
bring those together for
decades and i always have felt that what
we miss
obviously is a bias experimentalist is
the experimental clues to actually do it
that somehow thinking you invent string
theory to do it or something
may work but i think it's much more
traditional that we find clues
and so uh again i don't know how to do
it but i think
maybe the way to really study black
holes is for example some place where
both
worlds have to come together might be
with gravitational waves
so it looked to me even beyond what i
can see to do
in the next five years 10 years 20 years
that it's just a new approach so i was
romantically attracted in these kind of
ways
my late colleague at caltech my mentor
professor andrew lang who was your
colleague used to say that part of
making a successful experiment work is
that you fall in love with it
and you kind of lose all sense of
rationality at least at first
because there's sort of an irrational
attraction that happens in the beginning
because i can't resist this i had on sir
roger penrose last month
and i gently chided him i said all these
figures in
all these topics in shelley glacial's
book interactions
which i discussed with shirley glashow
recently
he talked about the way that theory and
experiment
in the case of at least quantum gravity
which you just brought up barry
there's this kind of you know feedback
cycle between uh
theory and experiment that we often hear
the same story that we need to
understand
singularities in uh space-time because
where they occur
namely in the big bang and also at the
center of black holes
these phenomena seem to require the
union of the very small with the very
strong gravitational fields
i pointed this out to sir roger and
shelly and other people
that we actually don't know what they're
such singularities it could be
that a singularity at the early
universe's creation
uh could be forever firewalled off from
our observations the same exact way
that black hole singularities are fire
firewalled off from
our observations um as well as
sir roger penrose has described so i
asked roger penrose and i'm going to ask
you
who says there has to be a unification
of quantum mechanics in gravity maybe
it's just our prejudice that we want to
unify things
yeah i i think you're right i i think
but
you know as scientists it's attractive
enough to think that you develop the
theory of physics that can describe
physics and you don't have two discrete
ones that you can't
somehow make talk to each other and so
it's attractive enough to think there
must be
a bridge between them i think that uh
[Music]
that it's worth pursuing can you really
can you really uh say that that ass
absolutely has to be the true pat the
path to truth i
i don't think so i think penrose is
right or you're right or whoever
says it it may be that that's a false
direction but
you know searching for gravitational
waves or cosmic microwave background all
these things that we do that haven't
been seen before are we don't know
absolutely we wouldn't be looking if we
knew absolutely that the direction
is the right so it has to be promising
enough promising and
that it might be the right answer and
promising and that you can
actually make progress actually lenny
suskin points out that black holes
horizons are as interesting as the
singularity
itself and they are just as quantum
mechanical he claims
perhaps even more quantum mechanical
this event horizon and what he calls the
stretched horizon
sort of like a firewall and you have
effect that manifests themselves at the
plank length
above the event horizon that he claims
will be visible someday with
instruments not too dissimilar from ligo
and it brings me to a question that
shelly glashow wanted me to ask
you and that's about contributions to
astrophysics with ligo
and that this notion that you mentioned
in your nobel lecture
last year or rather in 2017
about the prospects of measuring
primordial gravitational waves which you
did mention is sort of the
ultimate represented the ultimate
achievement in gravitational wave
science
and obviously as you think as you must
know i think experiments like the
simon's observatory
will be hot on the trail of these
primordial gravitational waves
but uh shelley wants me to ask you about
another form
of gravitational waves uh useful in
cosmology
perhaps to solve the hubble tension
well i mean we measured the hepa
constant actually
and we have uh uh it
in a few years i mean if this remains
attention
a decade from now i think we'll resolve
it uh
basically we we have uh a way that
doesn't rely on some without going in
the technical thing some of the biases
of doing this ladder business or
uh and so forth we basically it's a
pretty direct
measurement that you can make and
complementary with
gravitational waves and we have made a
poor measurement of it that
looks consistent with the whole thing
yeah but but that means you know we need
a thousand times more data or something
to pursue that i don't think we're
limited
by systematics just limited by getting
enough data uh we can't get that much
data
by continuing just to run ligo so we
have to make it better we are working on
making it better
i would say it's kind of to get enough
data on the on our measurement
independent measurement of the hubble
constant
to resolve that in a different way or
get a third measurement
at the level that they're doing it and
with the systematics that they talk
about is a decade away
but doable than ligo not a future
instrument i think the improvements that
we have to do in ligo it's not like what
i said about early universe or this or
that
which is going to require a different
instrument uh but that'll be done with
the improvements that we
will make in ligo along those lines ray
weiss he's coming on the show soon and
he wanted me to ask you a little bit on
the technical side of things
which i could translate into our own
language and i'd like to know
of these two different properties which
would you want to add
most currently uh to to improve ligo
if there's no obstacle technologically
or financially
and i don't think there is would you
rather double the sensitivity of ligo or
add on polar
polarization detection capability i
think that for me
is i think the clear uh path the clear
reason for sensitivity
which is what what i favor and what
we're working the hardest on
is uh not what i just said for the
hubble
which is getting more uh data and
getting enough data to resolve it
but basically being able to look further
out which is equivalent to looking
at higher z or higher red shift which
means that we can start to
at least think that we can start to
approach doing cosmology and not just
astrophysics with gravitational waves so
when i say it's a new probe
of the sky right now it's astrophysics
but if we can get to larger z then we
start to be able to do
cosmology with uh gravitational waves
and to me that's the biggest
advance in the in the coming 10 or 20
years that i
that i feel is the biggest driver uh
romantically is
to start doing cosmology something you
love of course so you probably
i like that answer
definitely i approve of that answer if
anything
you found it interesting as jim gates uh
has written a book about einstein as
well
and of course was one of the founding
fathers of string theory he was a
postdoc at caltech
in your early days he asked me to ask
you about the prospects for finding
perhaps scalar tensor evidence for
scalar tense or vector gravitational
waves
in ligo i don't know if that's something
about ligos potential capabilities that
interests you
it's it's of course it's interesting to
to gates
uh that's kind of his thing and we've
communicated about it
quite a bit uh we
it's not my deepest interest because
trying to look at alternate theories of
general relativity to einstein
uh i'm much more pragmatic as an
experimentalist the problem is when we
look at different
a step back for a second if we look at
different
theories in particle physics whether
you're looking at the higgs or you start
looking at different more dynamical
theories
in in particle physics we're able to
make predictions and then compare them
with the data
okay the trouble is including
gates work in general relativity what
right now we're
we're making some pretty damn sensitive
tests of general relativity for example
putting in a simple uh dispersion term
in these
detected many wiggles and gravitational
waves in the
merger of two waves if we put in a
dispersion term uh
in it which is equivalent to putting in
more generally something like a graviton
okay then we can set a very small limit
on it
but that the spirit of what i'm doing
there
and the spirit of what i do when i'm
testing general relativity right now
is just looking more and more
sensitively at the terms that einstein's
calculates and looking for a deviation
when i do something in particle physics
i'm used to comparing two theories and
one of them may fit the data well and
the other one not
here i'm looking for some breakdown and
einstein it's not as satisfying to me
to look for a breakdown in einstein's
theory therefore
must be there must be some alternate the
kinds of theories that gates is
interested in and other people are
don't predict what we detect at the
level that we actually can test in the
data and compare with einstein's theory
so theory is too far behind i think and
not not capable
of making it attractive to me as an
experimentalist that
it's a very unsatisfying kind of test
that we do now
uh may i ask you a question about the
philosophy
of experimental science there is a
aspect of karl popper's demarcation
philosophy
which is that you should only pursue
scientific things as those things that
can be falsified
but i want to ask you a slightly
different question on the experimental
side
uh when do you stop an experiment i mean
it's not like you know or for sure
when you should kill a an experiment the
way you might
kill a diseased worm pet or something
like that
so you have to have a certain amount of
judgment to know that it's better to
turn off the experiment and move on to
the next one than to slowly and slowly
get better
monotonically and just run experiments
like c and b
experiments forever and the question is
you know is there any sort of criterion
as
uh popper might have is there a bearish
criteria
rubric that we can use that's a good
question i i
i don't i you know i can answer it
personally but trying to answer it in a
way that's not
personally i mean i do what turns me on
kind of which is not it's deep
uh as that i think the the general
problem that we have
uh and why science
our kind of science doesn't move forward
faster than it does
is that the system
is too conservative
we we love something called peer review
but peer review
is actually very conservative because we
basically turn in proposals to do
something
if they're to get funded for example if
they're offbeat
i mean the theorists can do anything
they want they throw in the waste basket
but you and i can't
we have to go and get some resources and
we turn in a proposal
and if it's offbeat it doesn't get all
outstandings in the reviews done by peer
review so peer review is too
conservative and then if you get money
your money's private but
my money came from the nsf the nsf is
answerable to congress
and so if you do something that doesn't
uh that
is not very defendable then
you're not uh so the nsf uh
something as wonderful as the nsf to
support science
is far too conservative we have to be
able to tolerate
failures many more failures than we do
and experimentalness
should be basically turned loose to to
follow our dreams and and i think
science would move forward much
more some of us would fail at things
we'd have a lot more fun
and uh i think uh there's no
we don't have to be so analytical about
how we move forward
i i've never kind of had that in what
i've done
i mean i spent uh decades chasing
magnetic monopoles
and underground in italy and that
that was a problem that i was interested
in in high school so
uh and i you know i was nice to be in
italy but i basically
before i worked on the super collider
that's what i did i spent 10 years in
italy
i was chasing magnetic monopoles
but i could do that it didn't take very
many resources
actually the italians supplied a good
part of it
but that's the kind of thing that we
should do as you i mean i would
love i like businesses anyway but it
would be
better if i didn't have to be so goddamn
conservative
yes i think that's partially why
institutions like the simons foundation
and other
private institutions like the moore
foundation are more nimble
absolutely foundations are succeeding
not only because they're
supporting in projects like the simon's
observatory
but also because they can be more agile
they can take more risks
and they can take more rewards and do
more experiments and get those
experiments done early even if that
means failing
and so uh have you heard this rule
popularized by
uh malcolm gladwell but really based on
this study by anders erickson
about becoming an expert so how do you
become an
expert well according to anders ericsson
at least
maybe apocryphally or not you need to
spend ten thousand hours doing a
particular craft
so uh it turns out that he studied
bill gates and maybe other people like
the beatles
for example and he talks about this in
malcolm gladwell's book
uh that uh that the beatles played about
ten thousand hours worth of shows in
germany long before they ever got famous
people like bill gates had access to you
know computers
uh for 10 000 hours in their youth that
when the time came for them to apply the
kind of unique amount of training they
had done they were well positioned to do
so
and so i'm wondering about you your
opinion do you think that you need
some specific skill set because it takes
a lot of time
to not only become expert enough in one
branch of science as you did with
experimental particle physics to become
a leader
and and then to also apply it to lessons
learned for
a completely orthogonal branch of
science namely gravitational wave
astronomy and i remember when you were
here
last year at ucsd uh thinking about how
do you make
decisions on who to hire it's not like
you can't you can say like here give me
the pamphlet on how to run
a super project like ligo and last year
you told me you know
when i asked you for a shortcut for a
hack he said sorry brian
there is no shortcut um so i want to ask
you how did you develop
this this skill set well i think you
know
you have you have uh anything you should
do in life you have a combination of
whether you have the right ingredients
to do it i probably
have both the personality maybe the
analytical ability and so forth to do it
but i'm also humble
so uh when uh
physics started to require a fair amount
of resources i think i mentioned this to
you when i was in san diego
i went and actually studied how you
build a bridge and how you organize
things
and uh read the the the kinds of books
that they have it just doesn't take very
long to understand that there's a kind
of organization
to build a bridge that uh uh look the
dangers in building a bridge
are mostly that it's going to take too
long
and it's going to have technical
problems maybe occasionally that it'll
fall down
but usually the risk part isn't the big
part it's
kind of carrying it out so there's a
little bit on the wrist part but that
you do by over designing that scheme
doesn't work for what you do or i do is
very
clear to me and yet aspects of it
are essential to make sure that you can
reach the goals that you want when it
involves lots of people
so i was attracted i didn't mention this
to you last time i was
attracted to something that you may or
may not know about
which is called the skunk works the
lockheed and
skunkworks was named the skunk works
because it was named after little
abner's
the cartoon where there was a
this was a 1940s uh cartoon
which uh had uh an old warehouse that
smelled because it had
what it had in it was called skunk
s-k-o-n-k
and lockheed when they made the skunk
works which developed the u2 for example
uh when they developed the skunk course
it was a guy named kelly
and when he developed the skunk works uh
he called it skonk and
and they uh he got sued by the little
abner people and they now it's called
skunk works s-k-u-n-k
well that's the history but that but
what's in it the idea
of it is that they took a part of
lockheed and they broke it out and they
left these guys alone
and didn't require all the things that
we were talking about in
in in an organization all the
accountability and
and so forth and to me that had
uh some of the ingredients that you want
which is the
that you bring people together and they
interact and they have
the the freedom to pursue
uh things that are different from just
the straight paths and make bigger steps
so it's the closest i could come to
anything but it's wrong too
for what we want to do and it's wrong
for a couple of reasons one
one uh is that it's still a
hierarchical organization like and
uh basically we you and i live in
physics departments
which have emerged after a long time to
be a pretty effective place to do
science
and that organization is completely flat
it's not hierarchical at all there's a
department chairman who has
very can probably can't tell you what to
do even if they try
and uh then there's all these professors
and they do what they want
and the only difference is now you have
to bring it together to some sort of
uh common goal so uh
it's important i think in trying to
do what people have to do in building a
bridge but a highly technical bridge
first to not be
uh to mimic this totally hierarchical
organization which
doe tries to impose for example on the
dune project
at uh fermilab the
the the main problems in succeeding
technically in in terms of the way an
organization works
are that
you there two things i think are
absolutely essential first it has to be
done by scientists
because there's too many scientific
decisions so having a bunch of managers
doesn't work
so if you look at ligo or you look at
what we were doing at the ssc
all the key spots were scientific
sometimes in the same box if you want
you can put an engineer but
basically you want you're doing a
science experiment you need scientists
so you have to find ones that can live
in this kind of environment
there's two things that i think are
crucial and i've worked on a lot of
uh of experiments the first is that you
have scientists
not engineers uh we have plenty of
really super engineers in ligo but
it's a scientific organization
but the key to me which is not there at
all
in kelly's uh uh
skunk works is integration
so the big problem is for example in
ligo we have the world's
best laser people and we have
you know
[Music]
yeah we have a fantastic group of people
to do
controls and so forth but how do you
bring it all together to sing together
as one
instrument and what that requires is not
doing
what is done in building a bridge so the
key flaw for us in taking that style is
that they have
a very important role that they call
systems engineering
systems engineer if you go to jpl or
something is a guy
who's a very well-trained engineer who
draws all these interface
interface documents yes which do one
side and another side
it's just exactly the wrong thing what
you need for integration
and what we did in ligo is have the best
scientists
we can find have the job not of building
some subsystem
but integrating in our case it was
albert lazarini was the chief
one in in ligo a very very smart guy
very broad technically and
in anything where you had to bring two
things together you needed the controls
and the laser
to work together to run the laser or
whatever it was and
uh somebody that did the energy to the
interfaces just in a bunch of diagrams
it's somebody that's
able to make sure that these two sides
work together and that's
the control system's going to control
the laser in the right way and stuff
and so that required and so i think the
biggest
so you can draw all kinds of diagrams
and stuff but i think the real key to
success
is integration and the key otherwise is
that scientists
have to work on the different parts and
then you have to do something
to kill or to mute the change control
system that exists in a
organization because it again inhibits
change
anything that takes a long time to build
like ligo
uh things or even the the
cern experiment silicon requires that
you stay up to date
if you want to do something that you
couldn't do today and it's going to take
you a few years to do it you want to be
able to
be as current and forward-looking as
possible at all times
there's an inhibition against that when
you have a formal system
that requires you to go to a board and
change it and all this kind of stuff
which is built into these
standard organizations so you need to
have some variant of that but it
has to be again run by scientists that
has have a mission that basically
enables and encourages change not
but it's responsible to make sure the
change is worth doing that
it isn't a dream that it's going to work
and it isn't going to increase the cost
too much and so forth but
that's a practical part of it but you
should be
assuming change if you look at the ligo
we ended up with compared to what we
took to the
nsf in 1994 there's a lot of really
big change even the laser itself for
example
the laser that existed in 1994 was the
gas laser
i didn't like that from the beginning i
inherited that when i came in
and i always thought the future of this
was
solid state lasers but at that moment
they weren't as good they weren't being
made commercially and
so forth and and uh we switched very
early
to a solid state laser it required
a process that all the people that were
already embedded that
wanted to stay with a co2 laser
could buy off on afterwards so we needed
a process but encouraging change
and doing it responsibly is the opposite
to having this big board that inhibits
change and is great for making sure the
bridge comes in that you build on
costs and on schedule so somehow you
need
to have the and the
cost monitoring costs the important
thing there is to make sure that it's
not done by a separate group of cost
people but that it's inherent and the
people the the scientists again that are
running the
if the guy that's responsible for making
the laser has to be responsible for the
budgets and be
it has to be translated to him in a way
that he or she
understands the budgets and it's not
just a uh
something that's bureaucratic just to
maybe push on this a little bit
i found it obvious that in contra
distinction to building a bridge an
experiment
in research is something that you're
trying to really
figure out for the first time every time
in other words
uh there's no such thing as experimental
bridge design or at least i'm not going
to be the first person to walk over your
experimental bridge
but we often as scientists feel like we
are somehow
superior in a sense that we know better
than say a manager
uh you know in a project an engineering
project or even on a science project
that we know quantum field theory and
therefore we don't need to learn
uh how to manage people how to how to
run successfully
manipulate the resources that we have in
terms of
finances and time and maybe equipment
and marry those to this precious
extremely precious resource of human
capital how do we do that there's no
books and yet
there are you know perhaps resources
that we could employ
so i don't think we can do away with all
these aspects and just be totally
free-wheeling and
fancy free with our experiment um so i
want to ask you
uh is there any sort of at least way
that you were if you were a manager of a
project like the simon's observatory
what amount of effort should one put
into
say developing the best practices like
change control
the charter of the change control board
has built into it
different than what it would have if we
were building a bridge that's what i was
saying
and and so and we have uh
equivalent of systems engineering but
it's done in a way that
is optimized for our own problem it's we
i we call it integration but it's
basically making sure that it's not
done in the way that's done
traditionally so our our
organization might look superficially
very much like
and in fact it's a great trick because
our organization looks
like a standard organization and the
reviewers at
nsf or wherever don't get shocked by the
fact that it looks
like a skunk works or something it
doesn't it looks like a standard
organization
it's just that we've basically
changed the missions and who's in the
boxes and what they're doing and so
forth so
i i really was maybe saying it wrong
when i was i wasn't
i we're doing we've taken
what you call best practices basically
and
all of them and the way that is
optimized for our problem which is
not the biggest problem in us isn't we
have a problem of cost and schedule too
we have to meet budgets but it's not the
overwhelming uh feature and
and the one that you talked about the
fact that uh
technology that we're at the forefront
so we're limited by
technology generally and the fact that
technology can improve
or that we can make breakthroughs or
that we find new problems
as we go along we have to be able to
change things uh
not change them because they cost too
much or change them because something
didn't reach a spec
which is the way it happens on a bridge
but we change it because it's going to
enable us to do our science problem
better
oh yeah yeah
i i started uh my background
is that i i uh uh
i was born in omaha nebraska my parents
moved to los angeles when i was about 10
and neither of them went to college so i
didn't have any uh
real uh background they i
they're they were uh
they were uh encouraging for education
and being
a professional because it was a you know
a jewish background that's kind of
culturally built in
but i didn't have any of the advice if
you want her
encouragement they didn't know anything
my father's worked on cars and my mother
was a housewife and uh but i read a lot
as a kid
i i i i know you got interested in
astronomy at a young age but
i didn't i read science fiction i read
mystery stories because this to my
mother
read and and then i got beyond that and
i i grew up in hollywood uh kind of near
hollywood
west east hollywood and so i was around
a lot of
uh well what i would call storytelling
people have made
movies and are were into that kind of
stuff and i always liked storytelling i
liked writing and i
was always reading something so i liked
reading writing and so forth
and uh at about the age of 13 or 12 i
i discovered
good literature and so i really got into
storytelling and being reading good
books
you know the russian novels or whatever
you want and
so by the time i entered high school i i
certainly thought
that my life was going to be
writing novels or at least writing or
doing something like that
and not science i was always good at
math and things as we all are
kind of to get that far to get what we
are but it didn't mean anything much to
me
and uh when i finally uh
was cured of trying to be a writer
uh decided
i didn't know very much that i would go
to engine
do engineering and so i applied to
ucla and berkeley in engineering i
happened to graduate in mid-year from
high school
at that time they had mid-year
graduating and so i also had applied to
caltech
i had no vision to see beyond california
it's just my horizon was too short
and so i applied to and i was advised
not to apply to stanford because
at that time they were at least reputed
by the
advisor in my school to be biased
against jews
so i was told to not waste my time on
that but i did apply to caltech and i
thought i'd go to caltech because i
uh so that but i couldn't go in january
when i graduated from high school i
uh they took a class in september i
wasn't admitted yet anyway
and so i went to berkeley mostly because
it
meant leaving home and not going across
town
and started an engineering school in
berkeley you had to take another test to
do it
be in engineering and freshman
engineering there consisted of
engineering drawing which i love now
because you can visualize something
but doing it i had this terrible course
and then
as a excited freshman where i got
criticized as you said for my arrowheads
and that turned me off and then i had a
second course in
uh surveying we had this nice little
transit
and survey instrument went around the
campus
measured the heights of buildings and
stuff that was fun for about an hour
while you learned about the instrument
and then i was a shy 18 year old or 17
year old
and uh running around sitting on the
campus looking through this little thing
while
kids walked by and kind of made fun of
you did or i thought were making fun of
me didn't
appeal very much and at that time they
were i had to take freshman physics and
they were making
uh discoveries up at the radiation
laboratory and
and so i switched to physics and then i
got really lucky because
i switched to physics and then i got
assigned
an academic advisor and it turned out to
be owen chamberlain who got the nobel
prize for the
anti-proton and he invited me to come up
to the radiation lab
because i was pretty good in classes i
and i had extra time so i he
yeah so i used to go up there now the
radiation lab which is above the campus
has a little shuttle bus again
the anti-proton was discovered in 1956
and
they won the nobel prize in 1959 and
this is the period right in between
so you know he was busy as hell i
suppose i now
understand that the time between when we
saw gravitational waves and the nobel
prize was pretty busy
time too uh but he was too busy and
for me a lot of the time but i had this
overhead of going all the way up the
hill
so i used to wander up and and then they
didn't have as much
barriers for radiation problems and all
that stuff you could wander around
the bevitron was too intimidating for me
and nobody would talk to me i was a
little
17 18 year old kid but i wandered
up to the 184 inch cyclotron
and which is the classic machine that
existed there
and it was much smaller and it had a guy
in the control room who ran it
uh named who at the time i didn't know
who he was at all
is years later i saw his picture along
with lawrence and
alvarez and all these people he was
always the guy with a white coat and
stuff because he was their technical
his name was jimmy vale but he was one
person at the lab that would talk to me
so i i wandered into the cyclotron and
he he
uh he would talk to me and i uh
and he was running this machine and he
knew the art of running it
and that is the period when i actually
learned about control systems
not knowing that that's what i was
learning because he was he was he would
at that they would have oscilloscopes
and then a lot of
knobs because everything was analog at
that time not
now and so uh somebody wants to change
the energy of the machine
and so there's a big knob that had
energy and i'd well i'd be there
chatting with him and he changed that
now but he'd also go tweak
to something else you know a little
tweak somewhere i asked him why he would
do that
and he'd say because it works you know
basically
and you know it's somebody that grew up
with this machine and it worked
and so uh basically i i sat there and i
used to chart what he did so i
at first i thought i was charting it
because so i could
do what he did but eventually i
i learned uh that i learned to be able
that it basically
the control system wasn't diagonal and
so you have a matrix is the control
system an ideal one is is diagonal and
when you change the energy you change
the energy but here there's some
coupling between the energy
and something else and so the
off-diagonal terms are a problem and
that's
i i remember when i had all this big
insight and i showed the matrix
and the off-diagonal terms because i had
sat there and he didn't know what the
hell i was talking about and i didn't
either but i was arrogant you know
so uh so i so that was when i
really got into experimental physics it
was really through
sitting in a control room and then
that's how i got involved in doing
accelerators actually i did it
yes we talked about that last year that
part of the motivation for having the 40
meter instrument at caltech
you said that it was a training platform
that gave uh your students and even one
of my former students
darcy baron who's now a professor uh it
gave her hands-on experience
doing low risk but potentially high
reward science that she could learn a
tremendous amount
of physics experimental physics and then
be an asset to the project
and i know you only have a little bit
more time and i have a change control
board meeting myself but i want to ask
you a couple of questions
that come from your partner in crime ray
weiss
ray will be on the show in the next few
weeks and he wants me to ask you
about your thoughts for future upgrades
with ligo
and what kind of survey will you have
coming up with that and what's your
vision
we we we i think you know she should
have an interesting conversation with
ray because he's
uh really now the way he gets
like this about how we get from here to
there on
what we call the cosmic explorer which
is the next generation
uh there's not a clean set of ideas
about how long we keep improving
ligo before we change to a new
detector and then we have a second kind
of
issue which is that in europe they were
not constrained as we were
to think about a next generation
detector
and they did a design actually in 2011
supported by the
european um union i suppose some
grants and this is called the einstein
telescope
and we if we had not discovered
gravitational waves the nsf wouldn't let
us
spend a penny or even believe that we
were thinking about
uh you know next generation that we just
had to accomplish
i mean we did a little bit of thinking
but we couldn't really do any resources
so
so we've been since we discovered
gravitational waves and we're
and the older generation like ray and i
uh can afford to worry about the future
more than the young guys who should
exploit what's happened than they are
uh we've been working toward what we
call the cosmic explorer
and the idea is complementary to the
idea in europe although in the end
uh you really need to make globally
something that's
you know the same or that makes a more
a set of detectors around the world that
are practical and
right but the big difference is that
they they
are they designed uh the
next generation gravitational wave
detector that's deep underground
that gets rid of a lot of the shaking of
the earth problem
but of course there's the big overhead
and getting deep underground
uh it's triangular in shape which i
won't go into why that's good but that's
the way they do it for
uh the space experiment lisa it's try
it's a triangle instead of a l-shape it
gives you a certain
ability to go both directions uh to
inside know something about what
direction the gravitational wave came
from and so forth but it's again a big
overhead
in doing that and uh lastly
and the thing that i think is the
biggest next step for gravity
for technically for us is to cool
i mean the obvious thing is to go to low
temperature uh
it's not trivial the problem is going to
low temperature
we have these test masses which aren't
supposed to move
and yet we're supposed to suck all the
heat out of them
as the laser beam goes through without
making a move
uh and they're absolutely wonderful
mirrors
uh the quality of the mirrors are the
best super mirrors that exist
and the materials and everything
matter and the material that you used
at low temperature is not the same as
using the
and we're not material scientists so now
we're working with material scientists
and what to do
and what's the right temperature to go
to and so forth
uh so that's it but the biggest
overwhelming
problem practically is that about a
third of the cost of ligo
is the vacuum system not like the vacuum
system i see behind your head
a big vacuum system that is
is a third of the price of ligo itself
and now we're
we're talking about the way to get 10
times the sensitivity
is to make everything better but also
make it bigger so just stay on the
earth's surface
but make it 40 kilometers instead of 10
kilometers
we have to worry about the curvature of
the earth but that's secondary
the big problem is that if something
costs a third of the cost
and now you make it 10 times longer it's
the dominant cost
so how to make the vacuum system which
is
has to be big it can't be little for a
bunch of reasons i won't go into
and be high vacuum which it is and make
it much cheaper than it is before it was
before
is the practical overwhelming problem
and my my colleague ray wise is
wonderful at practical overwhelming
challenges
and so his so he he he
you know just pursue with him his ideas
for
how you make a vacuum system and
uh what tests have to be done and how we
get the support it's a little bit like
you were saying before how do we get
the support to do the r d on something
that isn't a going project and so forth
because
you just know it's going to be the big
problem but you want to work on it now
before we're proposing it we're talking
about being ready to propose
you know after cmbs4 is done or
something off the
table so we're talking about you know
the middle of this
decade we proposed it started it
started 2030 start building it you'd
like to have the next generation one
operational about the time of the space
one so they were
complementary but so that's 20 35 or
something but for us
we can worry about that because we have
tenure and have done our
but but but ray will will sing all the
ideas that's an engineering problem but
what's wonderful is how much science
goes into trying to solve an engineering
problem like that so how do you
make a much cheaper vacuum system that
has
that's a super high vacuum system we
have the largest high vacuum system
in the world and how do you do that
so before we leave i want to conclude
with some questions that i ask all of my
guests barry if you'll indulge me it
won't take very long
and the first one is based on a concept
in judaism called the ethical will which
in hebrew is pronounced and it basically
means something that you want to pass on
to future generations but not in the
form
of material wealth but an ethical and
wisdom-based wealth
that you can bequeath to your
intellectual biological
and ideological heirs as you know alfred
nobel
did this as well when he included a
requirement that the winners of the
nobel prize
would have to make humankind better
through their inventions and discoveries
even the ones that were winning it in
the sciences such as yourself
so i want to ask you what would you most
like to leave in the terms of wisdom or
ideology for future generations not only
for your children and grandchildren but
for humanity
as a whole yeah i i
uh i'm not going to be as philosophical
i'm going to be very practical
and answer the thing that i think is
singularly the biggest
uh problem in
that somehow maybe you and i evaded for
lucky reasons maybe different reasons
and in our in growing up so i grew up in
a certain family i didn't have
and so how did i get where i am uh
and who didn't get there they grew up
and why
and so the problem i think that is so
obvious to me
is that young kids you know five years
old
seven years old are incredibly curious
they're asking you questions and
pestering you want to know everything
okay
then we get kids that are pretty good
that come to
caltech they don't ask questions anymore
they just want to do their homework
they'll ask you a question because they
couldn't solve the problem
but somehow in the educational system
we kill curiosity uh i may be
overstating it but we basically kill
curiosity
and we even have a uh saying which is
detrimental it's curiosity killed the
cat
and that's actually telling you that you
don't want to you know you don't want to
try anything because it's going to cause
trouble
and i think if you find what happened
with somebody like you
or me or carl sagan made a statement
about this that i can't remember exactly
uh that somehow by some
piece of luck we evaded of this
problem that it got killed and for me
i've always been really curious why did
i spend 10 years looking for a magnetic
monopole
it's curiosity completely why uh
in so to get to where we are and you
don't have to be a physicist but i think
in life we have a real problem so so if
i don't just go out in the street now
we live in a society where uh everybody
walks around with one of these cell
phones
but do they know what it is how it works
at all most people don't have the
foggiest idea
how it communicates how it makes little
pictures on the screen what it is then
they go home
and they turn on their television and
they have no idea how there's
what made the picture there and they
don't even ask why
and then they go in the kitchen and turn
on the microwave to cook their dinner
and does it how many people really have
any idea what it's
doing to cook their dinner so we've
created a society
where people don't even have they've
been killed
they don't have the curiosity that we
all are born with is such a wonderful
human factor and so we've got to do
something about our education system
to encourage not kill curiosity
and to me that's the message that i
think anyone that's curious it's
wonderful
do it you're not going to get killed
it's so interesting that you bring that
up because
there's a something i learned which i
attribute to my friend james altucher
that he quoted when he gave his ted talk
in san diego he and i both gave
tedx talks in san diego and he quoted
that a five-year-old kid
smiles or laughs 300 times a day but by
the time they hit my age or your age
it's down to five times a day
so laughter like happiness seems to be
correlated with curiosity
and it also reminds me of another guest
in addition to james who has been on the
podcast
was a psychiatrist his name is dr judson
brewer at
brown university and he he looks at ways
to
overcome addiction such as smoking drugs
food whatever
wherever there's uh something that the
human mind can crave
he feels that the in this branch of
psychology
that you can overcome the addiction and
manage it
via becoming curious about the bodily
sensations that one is craving
so he says that the first thing you do
is become
essentially curious that's right that's
very interesting
okay 7442 yes the last question i want
to ask you
it hearkens to the name of this podcast
and it also involves curiosity and
imagination
and that's one of sir arthur c clarke's
so-called three laws
his first law is that any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic his
second law
which you and i can make good use of is
that for
every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert
and his third law is that the only way
of discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
a little way past them
into the impossible that's of course the
name of this podcast the arthur c
clarke center for human imaginations
into the impossible podcast
so i want to ask you what aspect of life
was perhaps mysterious
maybe even intimidating and terrifying
to you as a young person
but because of your courage or because
of your hard work and
discipline became possible because you
went a little bit beyond your comfort
zone
uh
well as as i said i think
uh i i didn't have a lot of mentoring
as a young person and i also was uh
in over my head some sense kids from
around me were more sophisticated or
came from more sophisticated homes
and so the big problem that i had
although it doesn't show so much now uh
is being overly shy
if you want not shy in the way that
uh you know you think of shyness but shy
in every aspect of kind of being a
person
that that i may in my head have been
very adventurous which i've always been
had curiosity but i was very
reticent until i got enough confidence
through success i suppose to
emerge later in life somehow i'm very
lucky that that happened
that i went down a path where where
i succeeded enough that i developed the
inner confidence but
otherwise i think i didn't have
the uh
confidence somehow in me to
to do what i was capable of doing and
that took a long time to develop
it's funny that you say that as well i
had on um lee suskin
this week and he basically basically
said this thing he suffered from what
people call the imposter syndrome until
he was 50. and he was
a you know he's in for the national
academy and i still have the imposter
syndrome
so the thing i'll tell you an anecdote
from the nobel thing
okay so mostly it's intimidating of
course to have this cane give you this
thing
but they walk you up at the very end
when they give you your check and so
forth they don't give you a check but
when you when you walk up
you go to the foundation nobel
foundation and they
take the official pictures of you and
all this stuff this is after the
ceremony
i don't remember the same day but you go
individually
and i went in and then they hand you
this little book
uh you know a book like kind of like
this not much more than this thing that
i'm holding in my hand
which you can't see very well and uh
but it's leather bound and so forth and
they opened it up to a page
and ask you just to sign your name okay
i'm curious right so i look back and i
look back and you look back on the
previous pages
and there's uh you know einstein
signature or
richard feinman yeah and
if at that moment you don't have the
imposter
syndrome which i certainly had you know
how do i belong on this
same page same book with a finite number
of pages and signatures it's not
like you know it's a telephone book or
something
that i think that i certainly
have had and i had it dramatically at
that moment and
well barry i so appreciate you and all
the generosity and graciousness you've
shown
me personally you don't have to do it
and yet you do it
uh there's so much here to talk about
your life and i hope you'll
come back in the future i hope i can
pick your brains and i don't drive you
crazy with other crazy
ideas that interest me but maybe not
interest you but i want to always uh
thank you for the the sage advice
yeah well i know this one's about you
interviewing me but
sometime we have to get together when
this pandemic gets out of our way
so you can tell me all about cmb and
what you really need
you can answer your side of the same
group of questions which i'm sure will
be different but
very interesting and saying so much
about i can do that very well
you owe me that is uh feedback that's
right
i'm happy to pay it back and i won't
make you find any leather
books uh barry thank you so much
everyone have a wonderful rest of the
day
and the rest of your week and i'll let
you know when this comes out okay
thanks bye
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
you